JB Smoove welcome
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh that's nice
he just removed Matt gorley's sweater
vest I don't know what you're gonna run
into a good a good v-neck
um
wow and when you find Tom and give me
the [ __ ] sleeves dude get those
sleeves
now let me let me ask you something uh
JB first of all you can't just uh point
to someone's clothes and demand that you
have that or can you at this point in
your career I mean yes you can okay
fashion is an amazing thing and you know
what they have something called the the
bow tie Exchange program you know what
that is if I'm walking down the street
and I see another bow tie guy and I got
my bow tie on and his bow tie matched my
outfit better than a band bow tie I got
on I take kids bow tie is this a real
thing he has to give it to me he'll say
wow my bow tie will match her outfit
perfectly and my bow tie will match
yours and we proceed to exchange goddamn
bow ties yes yes
yeah yeah you have to give him something
now don't you no no I don't gotta give
him [ __ ] you know why
you didn't keep it and but you have to
have a sense of style he is doing this
damn vest dirty right now he got on some
jeans and sneakers that don't even match
the [ __ ] fast yeah I know those
[ __ ] don't match wait you don't
understand if I do anything more than
that he berates me for looking like a
Tweed Victoria grown ass man there's no
reason why a grown ass man shouldn't
look and you know what you need to hang
out with me when I'm walking it's not
all about your clothing it's about you
it's you behind the clothing when I walk
into my closet you know what I hear when
I walk into my closet me me me me me me
me me me me me me me
everybody wants to wear me they want to
wear me my outfits want to wear me they
want to be around me all damn day
those are your outfits talking to you in
a high-pitched voice my clothes want to
be around me sometimes I gotta get in
the dryer with my clothes on you hear me
shut up you came into the uh room 20
minutes ago I showed up and then you
walk into the room and I thought how am
I gonna get on stage with this man you
are the best dressed man in Show
Business you really are this man is
always impeccably dressed you have a
lean silhouette you are in fine shape
your shoes are fantastic impeccable
impeccable yeah
you're supposed to act a little shy you
know you're not supposed to say Yes Yes
impeccable look at the heels on those
shoes those have diamonds on them these
are
always tell everybody out there no I
give good advice sometimes and something
might get [ __ ] up advice well I'll
tell you one thing you can't go wrong
with a pair of great shoes you can mess
those shoes up with anything and it
lasts forever if you take care of them
you're not gonna tell me how many times
I change the soul on these shoes
uh is that a rhetorical question
four times man four times wait you've
you've I've never replaced Souls on a
pair of shoes if you take care of the
leather and you condition it constantly
yo you can replace the soul on a great
shoe especially Louis Vuitton a Louis
Vuitton they will replace every goddamn
thing okay but wait a minute what kind
of way is that to spend a life
I feel like now you go home and you have
to go there are things you want to do
you want to spend time with your wife
you want to do something fun have it
like a nice glass of wine but no you
have to go and start rubbing conditioner
into your shoes
what fashion does here's what fashion
does sometimes fashion makes an
appearance and goes away you can't find
these shoes nowhere you can search the
internet far and wide you will not find
these goddamn shoes you better off
catching the dude wearing these sleeping
on the train and take them [ __ ] shoes
off his goddamn feet I don't think
that's right I think that's called
stealing